[Música]
y por supuesto en salud de directo
américa seguimos hablando el cáncer de
mama y cuáles son los datos de esta
enfermedad en la región latinoamericana
para ello ya está aquí conmigo en el
estudio más romeros a la mar buenos días
en la salud bienvenida muy buenos días
pues efectivamente empezamos decir
diciendo que el cáncer de mama es el más
diagnosticado en américa latina'
repasemos las cifras según cifras de la
ms en todo 2020 78 millones de mujeres
en todo el mundo estaban viviendo con
cáncer de mama de ellas habían sido
diagnosticadas en ese año 23 millones
462 mil sólo en américa latina'
además también en 685 mil muertes en
2020 también de las cuales 100.000
sucedieron en américa latina' como
decíamos desde el más diagnosticado en
la región y la segunda causa de muerte
por cáncer en américa latina' también
para hablar de eso estamos con carolina
wiesner es directora del instituto de
cancerología de colombia muy buenos días
doctor hay muchas gracias por estar con
nosotras desde las agencias de salud ya
se viene advirtiendo de que el cáncer de
mama puede aumentar un 30% en los
próximos años a qué se debe este aumento
en el continente americano
gracias mal por la invitación si
efectivamente la incidencia de cáncer de
mama está relacionada con el índice de
desarrollo humano este es un indicador
que nos muestra que hay una mayor
expectativa de vida es decir que las
mujeres ahora viven más hay un mayor
nivel educativo y hay un mayor ingreso
per cápita
en términos generales podemos decir que
los países de latinoamérica mayor del
nivel de desarrollo mayor expectativa de
vida tendremos un mayor número de
mujeres por encima de los 50 o 65 años
claro pasemos un momento del presente al
futuro para complementar lo que estaba
diciendo doctora de hecho la cantidad
precisamente esta incidencia de casos
diagnosticados en las mujeres se nota
mucho la diferencia entre precisamente
los países más desarrollados y menos no
veamos el gráfico también que les hemos
preparado las incidencias de cáncer de
mama en eeuu son mucho más altas por
ejemplo que en otros países de la región
americana y en rojo por ejemplo ven la
cantidad de muertes de mortalidad
también vemos precisamente en eeuu la
diferencia enorme entre la cantidad de
diagnóstico es altísima que hay pero una
mortal muy baja mientras que en países
como haití estas dos barras están muy
cerca eso significa que en haití para
poner un ejemplo hay una muerte por
cáncer de mama por cada 2,5 diagnósticos
raúl son unas diferencias abismales que
nos hablan mucho también de las
desigualdades en la región así es marc y
esto me permite entonces saludar a la
doctora primero doctora gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa y
preguntarle que explica no estas altas
tasas de mortalidad en algunos países de
américa latina
si efectivamente ese ha sido un tema de
grandes estudios aunque en américa
latina' el riesgo de desarrollar cáncer
de mama es muy inferior como se ve por
las cifras de incidencia si se ve a un
mayor riesgo de morir por cada por
cáncer de mama y varias pueden ser las
razones primero las de las mujeres que
pueden ser culturales o biológicas o la
de los sistemas de salud en términos de
las características de las mujeres pues
en américa latina' podemos tener un
número importante de mujeres que digamos
no tienen el suficiente nivel de
información y la cultura para examinar
regularmente sus mamas o cuando sienten
una masa iu como el cáncer de mama en
sus estadios iniciales no es doloroso
entonces posponer la cita para el examen
clínico de la mama o participar en los
programas de también sesión entonces
pueden ser razones culturales de la de
las mujeres en llegar de manera tardía a
los servicios de salud las otras son las
razones biológicas
efectivamente el menor riesgo de
desarrollar cáncer de mama se ha
identificado incluso si recientemente se
identificó un gen
cerca al receptor de estrógenos en donde
dice que va a hacer que las mujeres
latinas tengan un riesgo
comparativamente menor comparado con las
blancas no hispánicas de eeuu pero
también se ha encontrado que en las
mujeres latinas hay una mayor
probabilidad de desarrollar las
variantes más agresivas como son la
triple negativo sabemos que el cáncer de
mama es un conjunto muy heterogéneo de
enfermedades ahora con no solamente se
diferencian desde el tipo de vista
morfológico sino también desde el tipo
molecular y de la respuesta al
tratamiento clínico y la respuesta al
tratamiento clínico es muy varias
variables según estos subtipos entonces
en latinoamérica menor riesgo a
desarrollar pero cuando se desarrolla se
desarrollan los tipos más agresivos y
por otra parte existe propio salud él no
nos organizan adecuadamente la respuesta
a la enfermedad claro precisamente
estaba empezando a hablar también de esa
importancia de la detección temprana
hemos traído también unos datos para
para resaltar esa importancia son datos
de estados unidos donde se recoge la
tasa de supervivencia de 5 años después
del primer diagnóstico
vemos que en los casos de cánceres
localizados todavía es decir que no se
han expandido más allá del seno la tasa
de supervivencia es del 99 por ciento
mientras que en casos de cáncer ya
regional es decir que se ha extendido a
zonas del pecho como los ganglios
linfáticos por ejemplo ahí ya baja al
86% en los casos de cánceres distantes
que ha hecho metástasis en el resto del
cuerpo y en el resto de órganos la tasa
de supervivencia se desploma hasta el 28
por ciento por lo tanto muy muy
importante la detección temprana de este
tipo de enfermedad doctora hablemos de
las causas del cáncer también del cáncer
de mama sabemos que uno de los factores
más importantes son los factores
ambientales nos estaba empezando a
apuntar nos puede explicar qué son y
cómo nos afectan
bueno factores ambientales realmente con
las nuevas condiciones del desarrollo
industrial y urbano las mujeres tenemos
la tendencia a vivir en las grandes
ciudades en donde efectivamente ocurren
cambios de comportamiento por ejemplo la
dieta puede llevar a un aumento en la
obesidad mórbida post menopáusica que se
considera un factor de riesgo hay un
mayor consumo de alcohol y el cigarrillo
menor e menor actividad física es decir
se van juntando los factores de riesgo
en las grandes ciudades pero podríamos
decir que los de los principales
factores de riesgo se encuentra la
obesidad post menopáusica también hay un
factor muy pequeño que es el factor
hereditario mujeres que pueden tener
mutaciones en los genes brca1 y brca2
pero digamos que el 80% de las mujeres
no tienen factores de riesgo pues poner
la edad del primer hijo que hacemos las
mujeres cuando decidimos aumentar el
nivel educativo se pospone la del primer
hijo y en una época no sea promovía la
lactancia luego la
dar lactancia también se considera un
factor de riesgo y por otra parte las
mujeres que han recibido tratamientos
con radioterapia
grande exposición a la radiación
julieta en el en el pecho y el haber
tenido el antecedente de una biopsia que
muestre atípicas son como los factores
biológicos y los más contextuales sobre
esos factores una última pregunta que
queríamos hacerle porque hay varias
agencias médicas por ejemplo que listan
el uso prolongado de anticonceptivos
como uno de los factores de riesgo que
sabemos de eso que nos puede aclarar
bueno al respecto a los usos
anticonceptivos hay mucha controversia
al respecto
puedo decir de manera resumida que los
estudios en donde se ha encontrado un
mayor riesgo entre las mujeres que usan
anticonceptivos orales este riesgo es
muy pequeño es decir prácticamente no lo
consideramos pero algunos estudios
efectivamente han encontrado un ligero
incremento en aquellos que usan
anticonceptivos orales en estudios
grandes de seguimiento pero el mayor
énfasis del riesgo a mayor riesgo
desarrollar cáncer de mama se encuentra
en las mujeres posmenopáusicas que usan
terapia hormonal de reemplazo por más de
5 años pues doctora gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa en france 24 hablándole
a pues a nuestra audiencia no sobre este
mal el cáncer de mama que padecen miles
de mujeres al año estábamos con